what do you make of all the ridiculous
is about you and Brad reuniting on all
these carpets all season long its system
oh they're talking Brad Pitt and
Jennifer Aniston reunite first all at
the 2020 SAG Awards and were screaming
for every freakin moment our favorite
former couple both Juan huge tonight
Brad took home Best Supporting Actor for
his role in Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood I got to add this to my tinder
profile his hilarious speech was topped
off with of course a camera cut to Jen's
reaction the scene Jennifer took the
stage shortly after Brad winning Best
Actress in a Drama Series for her role
in the morning show I know that you know
the few times I've been invited back
into this room over the last
20-something years it's been so special
the times that I've been invited and to
be up here is truly an honor thank you
was it lovely welcome back it's been a
long time and that's why I met when I
said you know I know when this when I
kept biting into this room it's really
special because it's my it's my beers
but the moment that had the earth
shaking this
yep that is broad pit stopping
everything to watch Jennifer Aniston's
acceptance speech let's just take a
moment watch that again
okay we know they're just friends the
actor told us at the Golden Globes
okay the obsession the world the
Internet everyone is waiting they're
hoping for this moment where you and
Jennifer run into each other so they can
take their picture she's a good friend
but we can only hope for Brenna for 2020
to happen listen you got it can't beat
him join him right
[Music]